[Musik]
wie gerne würde ich so gut ski fahren
können
diese jungs sind so gut in snow baden
toll
ich hatte so viel spaß es ist eiskalt
heute sollen wir etwas heißes zu trinken
holen ja los geht's
[Musik]
sollen wir hier einkehren was sagt ihr
dazu
das sind die jungs von vorhin was für
ein zufall
reiter ich komm nicht mit ich brauche
ein heißes bad
ok marie wir sehen uns heute abend
bis später
also stefan was möchtest du bestellen
ich glaube ich nehme etwas zu essen das
fahren hat mich schon hungrig gemacht
[Musik]
verzeihung wir möchten gerne bestellen
guten tag was darf ich ihnen bringen
hallo ich hätte gerne eine heiße
schokolade mit sahne
ich nehme auch eine heiße schokolade
aber ich würde auch gerne etwas essen
können sie mir sagen was für torten sie
haben also wir haben natürlich
schwarzwälder kirschtorte aber auch
berliner ballen bienenstich und
baumkuchen
[Musik]
ich nehme die schwarzwälder kirschtorte
danke gut ich danke ihnen ich komme
gleich mit ihrer bestellung zurück
der tipp in der gelben jacke war
wirklich gut im snowboarden
und er ist auch so nett
wenn ich auch skifahren könnte könnte
ich mich mit ihm anfreunden und ihn
kennenlernen
stephan ich bin gleich wieder da
warum kann ich nicht warum
hey hallo
hallo
ich heiße hans und dort am tisch sitzt
mein freund stefan
hallo ich bin so viel hallo sofia schön
dich kennenzulernen
hallo hans veit nicht es tut mir leid
aber ich konnte nicht umhin deinen
traurigen gesichtsausdruck zu bemerken
stimmt etwas nicht was ist passiert
es ist nichts ich habe euch vorhin beim
snowboarden zugesehen und ihr seid so
gut
ich habe schon mehrmals versucht ski zu
fahren aber ich kann es nicht
ich habe unterricht bei einem lehrer
genommen aber ich falle ständig hin
und das macht mich traurig weil ich
wirklich gerne ski fahren würde
klar ich verstehe sagt mir hast du schon
mal snowboarden ausprobiert ich bin auch
nicht so gut auf skiern aber auf einem
brett ist das eine andere geschichte
nein ich hab snowboarden nicht wirklich
ausprobiert aber ich habe es aufgegeben
ich glaube nicht dass wintersport etwas
für mich ist nun ein warum versuchst du
es nicht du kannst mit uns eben wenn du
willst
wir kommen jeden morgen zu dieser piste
aber spät am morgen weißt du ich schlafe
gerne aus
[Musik]
danke aber ich weiß
nicht ich glaube nicht dass ich dazu in
der lage wäre okay wie du möchtest wenn
du es dir morgen früh anders überlegt
wir sind hier muss ich wünsche dir einen
schönen tag
gleichfalls tschüss
hey alles in ordnung
ja ja ist der kuchen gut
er war wirklich nett
vielleicht hätte ich annehmen sollen
[Musik]
mit
ihr wollt also zurück ins tal gehen da
das wetter immer schlechter wird weiß
ich nicht wie lange wir noch hier
draußen bleiben kennen sicher aber
zuerst muss ich dir etwas sagen 'du
sollst wissen dass unser hans gestern
nachdem du gegangen war ist eine junge
frau beeindruckt hat ach was du nicht
sagst und wer ist sie sie war wirklich
nett sie saß und der terrasse des chalet
in dem wir ein kehrten sie hatte einen
etwas traurigen gesichtsausdruck um
ehrlich zu sein aber es brauchte unseren
hans um das lächeln zurück zu bringen
unser herzensbrecher ihr 2 hört ihr wohl
auf euch über mich lustig zu machen kam
schon das ist ein witz sag mir wie sie
heißt worüber hat dir gesprochen
ich sprach sie an weil sie sich schlecht
fühlte sie erzählte mir dass sie nicht
skifahren gehen konnte und deshalb
traurig war
also lud ich sie ein sich uns
anzuschließen und snowboarden
auszuprobieren
aber sie hat mein angebot abgelehnt
vielleicht war ich zu direkt aber nein
das hast du gut gemacht du wirst sehen
sie wird ihre meinung ändern
jetzt lasst uns nach unten gehen denn
sehr schlechtes wetter zieht auf ich
wette es wird einen schneesturm geben
was für ein schlechtes wetter die
wetterprognose zufolge wird das wetter
noch zwei tage schlecht sein
wer weiß was hans und seine freunde
wieder in diese gegend zurückkehren
werden um skier snowboards
[Musik]
das sind sie hey sofia
das ist sophia die ich vor ein paar
tagen hier im chalet getroffen habe
sofia
das sind meine besten freunde stefan und
marie hallo zusammen hallo sofia ich
weiß dass du gerne skifahren lernen
würde es wir fahren schon seit jahren
snowboard hans hat auch schon ein paar
wettbewerbe gewonnen er wurde einmal
zweiter und einmal erster ich hingegen
stand nur einmal auf dem podest als
dritte es war so aufregend
aber wie ich schon zu hans gesagt habe
bin ich nicht sehr gut darin
ich falle ständig hin ich bin wirklich
schlecht darin aber wir können dir
helfen
ich lade dir mein snowboard damit du es
versuchen kannst was meinst du dazu
vielen dank du bist sehr freundlich aber
ihr lacht mich nicht aus bitte na sicher
es wird spaß machen du wirst sehen also
beginnen wir mit den grundlagen wichtig
ist den körper in einer linie mit dem
brett zu halten die arme offen und
entspannt die knie leicht gebeugt das
gewicht des körpers ist auf beide füße
verteilt und nur der kopf ist in
richtung abfahrt gedreht alles klar
probiere es aus
sie ist wirklich schlecht stimmt ich
habe noch nie eine person so oft fallen
sehen
sie sind jetzt schon seit zwei stunden
dabei
es reicht ich werde es nie schaffen sagt
das nicht noch einmal kommt schon
ich weiß dass du es kannst
[Musik]
ja das ist richtig
sehr gut ich habe es geschafft
ich glaube es nicht ich habe es ja
gesagt super danke für die hilfe
ich war überzeugt dass ich es nie
schaffen würde
machst du witze
alles was du gebraucht hast waren ein
paar ratschläge und ein wenig training
sofia
das hast du toll gemacht gib mir fünf
so ist es richtig jetzt sind wir alle
bereit zusammen loszulegen
[Musik]
wow das war unglaublich
habt ihr gesehen wie schnell ich
gefahren bin
was haltet ihr davon wenn wir uns um
zählen und diesen erfolg feiern so viel
hat das total verdient
klar ich kenne einen sehr schönen ort
der nicht allzu weit entfernt ist
vielen dank leute abgemacht wir sehen
uns um 19 uhr
[Musik]
anscheinend sind wir die ersten die hier
sind
ich bin hier
entschuldigung ich habe die zeit
vergessen
keine sorge sofia ist noch nicht da zum
glück
hallo hallo maria hier ist sofia
es tut mir leid aber ich habe den bus
verpasst
ich komme etwas später
kein problem bis dann sofia hat den bus
verpasst
also lasst uns reingehen und uns plätze
suchen während wir auf sie warten
[Musik]
hallo leute hier bin ich tut mir leid
dass ich zu spät bin
hallo sofia du siehst heute abend so
hübsch aus vielen dank
ich möchte einen toast auf unsere sofia
aussprechen weil sie gelernt hat
snowboard zu fahren und ihre ängste zu
überwinden danke ohne eure ermutigung
hätte ich es nicht geschafft
ihr seid tolle freunde
komm sofia ich habe eine überraschung
für dich
wir haben beschlossen die ein kleines
geschenk zu machen wir hoffen es gefällt
dir oh es ist wunderschön so kannst du
jetzt jederzeit mit uns mit kommen wenn
du willst
ich danke euch vielmals wir werden einen
tollen winter haben wir werden so viel
spaß haben
weißt du so viel ich bin froh dass ich
noch etwas zeit mit dir verbringen kann
ich auch hans
hey leute in der stadt gibt es ein
feuerwerk seht mal
möchtest du weitere kleine geschichten
sehen
daumen hoch wenn dir das video gefallen
hat und hinterlasse uns ein laie
aktiviere die glocke damit du kein neues
video verpasst hast du noch fragen
brauchst du sie in den kommentaren